uber is national dessert month so we
send rocky on a really tough assignment
ted and kirsten asked for this
assignment but we sent rocky
learning how to make marie calendar's
famous pies
as the restaurant celebrates the kickoff
of their fall
pie sale hey there rocky
hey brian yeah sorry not sorry okay you
guys listen
i've been you left me here by the way we
had you know some time
um with with the governor speaking and
i've been eating shrimp salad i've been
eating pie and
i'm just i'm ready for a nap now but
that's what marie calendars does it's
comfort food
and now for fall it's pie it's dessert
yes and right now we're definitely there
it's on sale
all the pies are on sale starting at
7.99 yes so they can come out and try
it's a great deal
yeah it's a great deal from banana from
funkin you know apple
so definitely it's the time all the
classics all the classics and
of course the fall specials like the
pumpkin you gotta have your pumpkin
everything
okay so what i want to do now is show
you guys how simple it is
to make the famous french apple pie yes
yes definitely you need to start with a
dough make sure you have the right
concentration on the dough uh
after that you make your juice your
chill okay and then you're gonna drop
you want to
do it okay drop it in and i'm not i'm
not
i'm not a baker by any means so this is
so make sure you have the right apples
grammys meat are the best but you can
try the different ones
you want oh my gosh yeah and definitely
feel they're all i mean they're not
we're just gonna uh
by itself what's next what's next yeah
and then you're going to add this one
and then we're going to bake it
yeah okay yeah you can definitely okay
do it all wrong all right you got to
make spread it all over
all around okay and then that's what we
have after we bake it
how long does it take to bake about 45
minutes to pick them up that's not bad
yeah that's right no
just make sure we don't burn it it's
also something you can do with your kids
you know
family you guys can come here and also
buy the ingredients or buy the crust and
make it yourself
yep yeah definitely if not you need to
stop by and get one
yes which is what i prefer which is what
i prefer
okay and also what else how else do you
guys celebrate the season here marie
calendars i know you know well right
healthy dinners
yeah definitely right after price so
we're going through our thanksgiving
we saw the fees we actually it's a meals
for four to six people
right so you can just take it home heat
it up and get ready for for the holidays
you know for thanksgiving okay well it's
obviously community favorite a
national favorite everybody loves marie
calendar so i think the two of us
you know since we've been hanging here
all day we should have some pie together
why not you guys definitely do you have
a slice anywhere
i don't have a life you can't definitely
oh i'm sorry i mean it's just because
it's right it's right being greedy
okay
you can't go wrong no definitely what
separates your pies from
everywhere else well i think uh i'll
taste honey
it's definitely a homemade we bake it
every morning and all different 20
different flavors
uh so we have a couple locations here in
vegas one henderson so definitely
just to stop by and get you know get one
get one get two get three
yeah that's right family parties you
know small group gatherings
absolutely all right thank you so much
angel thank you great calendars guys
i will send it to break and then we'll
be back